oh my god it's going in there wonder
perk is the movie about a little girl
named June who creates an imaginary
amusement park that gets brought to life
and we cannot wait to see it
so in preparation Jackson's gonna go on
his very first roller coaster I'm
shagging I really want to go on the
roller coaster so bad how long have you
been waiting I think a thousand years a
thousand years I've been there for every
single one of Jackson's births first
bath first time wearing underwear
instead of a diaper
we've been through it all I think I'm
notorious for being a giant staff about
anything relating to my kids you're
proud of them you're happy but you're so
sad because each milestone means that
they're getting bigger I think it's
gonna be faster than those trains that
look like a bull it's pretty nice right
when you go in a circle and the land
down underground then you see a
humongous Toy City if I could've met a
ride it would be a roller coaster but
instead of being strapped into a seat
you were strapped onto a bed you can
just take a quick power nap and there's
a drawer full of snacks do you want to
try a roller coaster simulation
so it's gonna start by going up lean
back as we go up leave to the people
down below yeah okay and I think it's
the top at your hands up cuz the soon as
it drops you're gonna scream all the way
over right we're gonna go back over to
left and then you're gonna hold my hand
as we do one more drop one two three a
[Music]
little higher and a little higher
[Applause]
do you think you're ready yeah okay
let's go
we're here at the park we pulled in and
Jackson was like whoa here's a
rollercoaster Wow mo man I'm sure let's
see if you're tall enough turn around
boom you're good to go you know what the
coolest part is we have the park all to
ourselves for this I'm getting on first
ready here nice and tight are you
nervous a little bit
this is always the scariest part and
then once you go it's really fun do you
want to hold hands
[Music]
you're the bravest kid in the world I
was screaming way more than you were it
was so fast I was like this ah and my
mouth the ones like this what was your
favorite part of that roller coaster how
do we know what the water went over the
water it was so cool and look Gary was
it awesome getting your first roller
coaster ride yeah I'm so proud of you
okay you're growing up so fast
that's cool okay are you ready to go see
wonderful yeah I still
[Music]